what if there is a show where former NFL
players could open up the vault of
stories they've never revealed before
well now you have one these stories come
out on the art gridirons new show untold
stories check it out on the BR app back
here on the Rich Eisen show and pleased
to have right here back in studio one of
our favorite guests to talk college
football and so much more from the
athletic Foxsports college football
analyst who was part of the broadcast
last Friday night when USC shocked Utah
using their third string quarterback now
it's USC ranked 21st taking on number 17
Washington 3:30 p.m. Eastern on Fox part
of the broadcasting Bruce Feldman good
Caesar good to see you what is the story
so far overarching one month in
essentially the college football season
and the story is fill in the blank I
think the story is yea Clemson and
Alabama are the two teams everybody
thinks is great they haven't played
anybody yet Ohio State's been dominant
they haven't played anybody yet the one
thing that's kind of been a surprise and
maybe it's a pleasant surprise is that
LSU it's not just you know your brothers
LSU your father's LSU anymore right they
got a big-time offense Joe burrow former
Ohio State quarterback you know they're
hitting the gas with with this pass game
it came from the Saints with Joe Brady
who's a Sean Payton disciple and it
doesn't look like LSU anymore now can
they overtake Alabama in the SEC West
who knows after that I think a lot of
people are saying you know we haven't
seen a lot of big games yet we just saw
Notre Dame hang with Georgia but lose
but short of those two games I feel like
it's been kind of an underwhelming slate
and we're only starting to get warmed up
well I mean and then if you want to
include teams at the top that have been
a story line definitely has to you have
to look at Oklahoma and Jalen hurts and
what he's looked like in this Oklahoma
offense yeah we had that Riley right we
had them their last timeout our crew did
the UCLA game and you know it's
impressive because this is the third
transfer quarterback who has gone into
play for Lincoln Riley this is actually
the most accomplished one in terms of
what he done before horse Baker was
pretty good at Texas Tech column er II
didn't do anything in Texas A&M Jalen
hurts people may forget was like the SEC
Player of the Year as
freshmen and I'll say this having spent
a little time with jaylen he has a
burning desire to to get back to that
national title game I mean it's just
both just that the surface right well
Oklahoma fans who I know and have told
me what they really like about jaylen
hurts is he's common brought a sort of
for the lack of a better phrase Nick
Saban Alabama mentality that whatever
he's done doesn't matter it's all rat
poison essentially the numbers say that
yeah I mean like he's brought that in a
way where obviously Kyle Emery didn't
say much Baker we all know what he what
he brought but hurts is kind of bringing
that that mentality to this position
that Oklahoma yeah and I you know I
asked in Lincoln Riley I said you have
three very different personality types
there with Baker certainly being
boisterous and he said of the three he
said Jalen's probably a little closer to
the Cuyler in terms of he's not as
boisterous right but there's there's
definitely an edge there and one thing I
would say with him is a lot of times we
default to okay that kid is this or that
you know you almost refer to the college
guys as kids you don't do that what
Jalen hurts he like even when he was 18
he did not seem like a normal eighteen
year old and now he's been through a
bunch I mean you talked to him and
sometimes stuff will kind of come out
where he's gonna you know this kid just
hid this guy right graduated with a
degree in in public relations he has a
pretty good perspective on what he wants
to put out there and the way he's gonna
put it out there and I think he's
mindful of that you coupled that with
Alex cringe taken over on defense he
done a really good job at Washington
State and I think his mentality is
listen you guys can give up a big play
but don't break when you give up a big
play and I think that is different in
terms of shaking things up because
Oklahoma had been really mediocre
they've they got to fill out basically
and spider their defense and I think
those two things really change the
demeanor of what Oklahoma is can it get
them into the playoff again and win
playoff games I don't know if I'd bet
against Jalen Hertz after being around
them for when granny you sillies not
you know they're not a top 25 team at
this point or anything close to it but
you just see how they operate and it's
one thing to do it against air it's
another thing to see to see kind of what
the standard is and I think the standard
has changed in Norman Oklahoma because
of those two guys on both sides of the
ball
Bruce Feldman here from the athletic and
Fox Sports on the Rich Eisen show it's a
few weeks until I bang this drum as I do
every year so I might as well
front-loaded just seeing all these games
and even though I know you said the
schedule has been soft for a ton of them
and they ass but it just seems to me
that when it all comes down to it I'd
love to see eight teams battle it out
this guy you just mentioned about LSU
and obviously Ohio State with Justin
fields it's possible Ohio State gets you
know picked off once maybe twice in the
big ten season I don't think so
the same thing with Wisconsin same thing
with Oklahoma LSU Georgia I mean one
loss should not disqualify teams that
are seemingly stacked like this right um
you tell me if I'm I'm off you know I'd
like to see eight teams as well because
I think right now you have six teams
that seem like they can get in the
playoff and win a playoff game correct I
there's some other teams I can get in
the playoff I don't think they would I
just think there would be overmatched in
that you know what you could even say
maybe a seventh team I was impressed by
what I saw with Notre Dame they still
had some injuries went into a really
hostile environment in Athens and held
up and acquitted themselves really well
against Georgia so if you want to say
the the seventh team they would
certainly have to run the table and go
11 and one because they have no
conference title game to prove
themselves to get a little boost but at
this point I one thing i would would
point out is about who has the you can't
who has a little margin for error
clemson zyg is as talented as anybody
but as bad as the ACC is this is the
worst conference from like after Clemson
that we've seen in a long time there are
maybe Virginia's as a top 25 caliber
team after that nobody is really close I
mean you see it when Boston College look
like one of the better teams in the
conference and they got blown out by
Kansas and Les Miles the week after
Coastal Carolina beat them you know you
see Miami is down
Florida State is down those are the
standard bearers you know in addition to
Clemson traditionally of those programs
that are in there of those brands
Virginia Tech is down it's just it's you
know Syracuse gets blown out by Maryland
I think that's a problem where I think
Clemson is gonna run through the ACC
including the title game and what I
wonder about is they won't get tested at
all
will that come back to bite them when
they match up with somebody with similar
town in the playoff it could I don't
know they just look so talented and the
kid we seen on the screen when I hear
radio on it says Trevor Lawrence I mean
really uh he's just so amazing to watch
and then you know the running game and
then the wide receivers I mean every
single wide receiver you see in the NFL
one one invariably
not every single but every that Clemson
is just a factory when it comes to the
defensive linemen that come out of
Clemson now it's yeah and it's so I mean
you can put them in right now it's what
I'm saying like if you can put them in
right now when you're gonna put Alabama
in right I would say Clemson is this
close to a lock as you will ever get in
late so I know and and and and Alabama's
pretty damn you're close to it too
pretty close I think they they have to
lose twice to not make it Bruce you know
you and I both realistically and our
size so what if that's why I'm saying
eight let's just let's just for just for
now it's now forget about October it's
now with the way scheduling is in
September it's now affecting the way I'm
watching football in September I'm like
okay I'm now gonna see sit here for the
next few weeks and and wonder who the
other two teams I'd rather sit here and
say who could be six who could be
currently tenth that can get into that
spot it makes it much more interesting I
would hope it wouldn't affect how you
watch it I mean anybody who stayed up
late on Saturday night I don't think
granted Washington State was undefeated
at the time I mean that was a fun game
the craziness yet in pac-12 after-dark
is a reason to watch there are no
playoff teams gonna be a last time I
guess also Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show also I've been turning
my alma mater off at halftime two out of
the last three weeks so that might be
dealing into a two so let me get into
this here I'll ask you what tons of
people are texting me and asking me and
emailing me and calling in to the show
what is wrong with
you were so high oh I was so high I'll
tell you where the area where I feel
like it's been the biggest debt of this
is I thought they were going to have the
best offensive line in college football
they don't have one of the best
offensive lines even in the Big Ten I
mean they were a real disappointment
last week and I think what you've seen
right out of the gate Shea Patterson I
know he got banged up and you know I was
dealing with an oblique injury early on
but you know the turnover is you cannot
get into any kind of rhythm if you can't
trust trust it with ball security and so
there's been that they've had breakdowns
in in protection with the backs and then
the defense like Don Brown who was this
wizard up till Dwayne Haskins got ahold
of him at the end of last year they've
been in a free fall and it just seems
like a team that has lost its identity a
little bit lost its its confidence and
you know I know Josh Gattis pretty well
he's the first time offensive
coordinator there and play caller I mean
he felt like one of the biggest things
he could bring there was a jolt of
confidence to the offense and it doesn't
look like a team right now that has that
because the best thing to have is they
do have really talented wide receivers
but I think right now both quarterbacks
have been banged up McCaffrey got
drilled last week and it doesn't look
like he's gonna be available to them and
and Patterson has really struggled until
they can find something they can hang
their hat on to get into a rhythm I
think it's gonna be really hard for them
and I did see got us this week made it I
thought it at least a compelling point
say look a couple of years ago he didn't
mention that he was it was Penn State
but he was at Penn State they started
out two and two they got blown out by
the Michigan Wolverines they lost to
somebody else and there was a lot of
people wondering is James Franklin gonna
make it at Penn State right and then
they got it turned around
you know they had sake want race
McSorely and I don't think Shea
Patterson is Trace McSorely or anything
close to that well that's a problem that
is a problem I mean look certainly when
we're and we're about to talk to you as
about us see in a second Bruce I mean
USC's goes with the third string
quarterback and and wins a football game
against the top ten opponent that they
have to win in the house with Reggie
Bush there and Urban Meyer their coach
on the hot seat and the ad having quit I
mean
that happens there and and you're
sitting here saying that the quarterback
that Michigan went and God as a transfer
isn't trace McSorely who's you know who
was terrific for Penn State but that's
that's a problem but that is a high bar
trace mccoy there was a great college
quarterback i admission michigan should
have one of those I'm being very honest
I might be biased but Dylan McCaffrey
might be that guy right down the road
right now
again I could and look a couple of
things I don't know five years ago in
Ohio State wins the national title they
look awful on the offensive line early
on the same old line coach is the old
line coach in Ann Arbor ed Warner was
the guy who was the old line coach when
they were really bad at the beginning of
the year and they got much better by the
end of the year where they wore the best
offensive lines in the country if they
can have that kind of growth and they
need to do it and obviously they were
banged up on the often you know a tackle
but you know look and and one thing
that's not gotten said in here is enough
Wisconsin was really impressed or a fan
and I think you got to give a ton of
credit
Taylor is amazing I'm gonna see him in
at the combine in Indianapolis and all
because he's checked every box every box
and and this is he's leaving right this
is the end of his stay there running
back he's I mean so I think I'm gonna
hear his name first five names in Las
Vegas next year potentially maybe so I
mean that's how good he is he's Chris
honor if you've watched his kid play
football have I mean have holy cow he's
made me some money on this track kid I'm
big on to Harvard I mean just I made you
fall in love with the kid when you're
around him and then he delivers on the
field the only issues he had early on
were he had some ball security issues
and he wasn't a great receiver no he
shored up that and he's gotten to be a
better receiver and the quarterback
there Jack Cohen is playing well the
thing that I would be most disappointed
with it allows a Michigan fan is that
was coming off a bye week that's the
worst part of it so what what happens
here what do you think is how is there
something brewing here cuz that's what I
get all the time to really like if
you're a Michigan person and you
obviously you are yeah Jim Harbaugh one
has won 10 games in three of the last
four years I know I mean they hadn't won
they'd won that one find a bigger
Michigan like tomorrow if you were a
Michigan person you go like this isn't
working out with Jim Harbaugh I
my doubts like I don't buy that that
Michigan has some kind of glass ceiling
that they can't Penn State coming off
sanctions and in a dark cloud one a Big
Ten title a couple of years ago there's
no reason why Michigan can't do it they
have all the resources what I don't get
is if you say and look maybe Jim
Harbaugh says you know what whatever
reason I got you know I have kids I'm at
this stage in my career I want to go do
something else in the NFL I mean is do
all the time but just think you're gonna
push him out the door who are you gonna
bring in that that was more you had more
confidence in winning than you had in
Jim Harbaugh there isn't that guy that's
correct
well I mean all the trolls what on the
message boards is saying Urban Meyer
take the job yeah
could you imagine he can't say the name
Michigan he's gonna take the jobs absurd
yeah I mean I think Matt Campbell's a
great coach but but Matt Campbell's no
there's no sure thing that he's gonna go
in an arbor and win there and I'm not
sure he'd want to take it I have no idea
that so I want to before I let you go
Bruce Feldman you were at the Coliseum
last Friday night and you're going to
cover USC Washington this week and they
are gonna go with their third string
quarterback
it looks like Keaton slovis who's that
really talented freshman quarterback
still in concussion protocol I was out
there last night so we're not sure if
he's gonna it's very if he's gonna play
so Matt Fink who was the hero on Friday
night Scott's got some experience and
they got great receivers just throw it
up he plays aggressive he lets them make
big plays and and Michael Pittman and
Tyler Vaughn's those guys do it but a
little who's who's fourth that's the
great question we should we know who the
fourth stringer is because that's the
kid who's gonna win the football game as
the sideline guy I'm like because they
already had another quarterback who is
Jack Sears started the game last year
he's not even with the team now he's a
regular student there this was during
the games there's a game and I can't
talk to clay Helton in the middle of a
quarter or one of the other coaches but
I can talk to somebody on the staff if I
know a recruiting guy right I grab one
of the guys I was like hey by the way
who's your emergency quarterback and the
Sphynx out in the game this is as Fink
is out in the game it's early on and he
was like uh that guy it was a Quitman 27
he was like yeah that him and I was like
27 and he said well he's a safety but
he's been the scout team quarterback he
came from junior college and he was a
walk-on so I talked to this kid you
today brandon Purdue his dad is a
veterinarian who actually is the
veterinarian for traveller and so when
that's the USC horse that runs around
his dad is the doctor this is a little
bit like a Disney movie because the kid
he said when I'm like you know five or
six years old I'm at the Coliseum I'm
around the you know around the players
I'm watching them run out of the tunnel
I'm thinking somebody that's gonna be me
well then us he got the sanctions and
they weren't allowed to have the little
kid on the feet holds with the horse but
you know that kid will get his shot if
this is a Disney movie then travellers
gonna be the backup kicker and kick the
game-winning yeah that's true I don't
know travel was allowed in husky state
although Gus was a kicking mule just
let's just be consistent for everybody
out there um so is that really is that
gonna be the quarterback depth chart
going into wash yeah I mean like for USC
I mean maybe Tyler Vaughn's who's a
super talented receiver and I watched
him he threw a couple reps he's got a
big-time arm but he's never played
quarterback so as Graham Harrell said if
something happens we got to get creative
and how awkward is it let's be honest
here that that urban is in them in the
building for that sort of stuff I mean
that's how big a win it is right because
everybody thinks that this is the guy
who's gonna replace it or at least
everybody in Los Angeles would
absolutely love of urban wanted a coach
again and be the coach of USC is that is
that unspoken pretty much yeah I don't
you know I don't know what these USC
fans some of these diehards I think
they're really conflicted they want to
see their team win but there's a lot of
them would like if he keeps winning we
can't make a change and I think a lot of
them as much as everybody likes clay
Helton as a as a person he's just a
decent nice man right but I think a lot
of them have never gotten over the fact
that they didn't think he should be the
head coach in the first place and he's
won a conference title he's won a Rose
Bowl
I mean look he's down to his third
string quarterback they just beat a
really good Utah team they sure did so I
don't know I mean his Urban Meyer gonna
come back I mean I work with him I'm not
sure how many people know what
ultimately he wants to do does he ever
want to come back I mean he's still you
know he has the cyst in his head which
was I mean I did one of the games where
he was on a knee and looked like he was
in agony that was Maryland right that
was that was uh
Nebraska game well I remember the Oh
Ohio's yeah there's one game that called
timeout and he wasn't even the huddle
he's doubled over yeah so I I mean look
I think there's a I don't think it's a
slam dunk that he would come back and
worry that he would come back to USC I
mean you know if clay helm wins this
game and then goes wins Notre Dame in a
couple of weeks I mean I don't know how
you how you again he's down to his third
string quarterback you know listen you I
see on the hook for several more years
right isn't that something our but USC
has a ton of money I mean I don't let's
not let money stand so grand it's not
mine or your money but that's gonna be
an issue okay so so like what Jimmy
Iovine just cuts a check or Spielberg
cut sure there's Danny dimes and the
hung Emily who's got and just again one
more time
Danny dimes was never around dude he's
Durham North Carolina are you kidding me
come on so there was no Danny dimes at
Duke there was no where no if Danny
dimes played at Rutgers maybe I'd buy
that exactly exactly yeah and somebody
you know pulled up in stugots you know
Durham North Carolina I have yes I mean
it's not there's no time there's no
Danny dimes where he was going down to
Johnny - time Johnny T times know at
Bruce Feldman cfb on Twitter I follow
him you should as well he could check
him out on Instagram at Bruce Feldman
fox and you can check them out on Fox
USC Washington this week 3:30 p.m.
Eastern Time have a great time up there
in that beautiful part of the country
sir thank you guys you gotta that's
Bruce Feldman here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app